España le dice por fin Adiós al llamado
voto rogado un sistema de votación para
los censados en el extranjero que hacía
del derecho a votó una Odisea
burocrática desde 2011 los que querían
votar tenían que pedir las papeletas por
correo tradicional antes de cada cita
electoral unos documentos que muchas
veces no llegaban a tiempo los difícil
de este trámite hizo que la
participación se desplomara del 32% en
2008 A menos del 5% en 2012 es decir las
primeras elecciones generales tras
instaurarse este sistema ahora los
españoles residentes en el exterior
recibirán automáticamente la
documentación para votar o podrán
descargarla por internet también se
amplía de tres a siete días el plazo
para ir a depositar el sufragio en los
centros habilitados Eso sí el voto
telemático aún no es una opción Aunque
el gobierno podría habilitarlo en el
plazo de un año esta reforma de la ley
electoral exigida por la sociedad desde
hace más de una década facilitará el
ejercicio democrático de más de 2
españoles emigrantes de los cuales un
54% vive en América Latina la derogación
del llamado voto rogado entrará en vigor
este mes de octubre por lo que se
aplicará en las próximas elecciones
autonómicas de mayo y en las elecciones
generales previstas para finales de 2023